this is time sandwich I'll do you say
about this episode entire episode about
a sandwich pretty much Jake makes the
pretty much it looks like the greatest
sandwich ever made IV as like you know
the soul of a lobster I'm quite fresh
bird you know fresh off the windowsill
into the sandwich and just all these
incredible things there's most pickles
hello what were they
remember prismo from the oh that's right
oh yeah and that and that was like the
what he had Tears for salt yeah so but
the magic man comes then steals the
sandwich but he wants to enjoy it as
much as he came wants to savor the
moment so he puts himself in cadiz time
bubble where he goes super super slow
which is really funny I think that yeah
very funny idea after giving a riddle a
riddle to get his sandwich back which is
I can't repeat it something like 7:20
when the leaves are yeah and you're
upside down oh so they're frown upside
that I don't know but I just know that
meant 7:20 could also be a sad face
which is that really a thing
no I'm trying to think my head how is
7:20 a sad family trying to get upside
down the sound I can't see this so I
don't know I don't know potentially is
us they're like 7:25 no no no 7:20 would
be really still would be or should be
8:20
no yeah 8:20 would work or 7:25 if
somebody can figure out how 7:20 means
sad face go ahead and post it cuz I
really don't know maybe it's like a
common knowledge thing we just don't
know what everybody else knows that I
don't nobody out it just seems crooked
to me looking at a clock you know and
even if it's not you guys not a common
now it's saying you just made it up
somebody find a way cuz now I'm really
curious somebody out there has to be
clever enough to make 720 a sad face now
it's like it's like a challenge ok or
something everybody knows either way
are gonna be either dumbfounded or just
dumb so it'll be great
and I figured that one probably so okay
so we got so he's in the time bubble the
whole thing is just figuring out how to
get Magic Man out of the time bubble to
stop him from eating the sandwich and
again
bubble gum there BMO has a plan
Marceline gets it I mean everyone just
gets stuck in this time bubble and
finally figures out that jake has to be
sad or to enter the time bubble so he
does but he has to stay sad so he thinks
up this scenario where mr. cupcake is
moving in on Rainicorn so that makes him
angry so then he thinks about how him
and mr. cupcake never got to hang out
after he's dead and this probably longer
that needs to be complicated story which
was very funny I appreciate it for how
needless it was um and finally breaks
the bubble and all the things that they
set up fall a magic man that was a great
payoff and I love BMO adding him I love
Marceline coming down I loved him
hitting the explosion all that stuff
that was great that was really really
cool um I'm really funny and then Jake
gets his sandwich he fights it and he
likes it um I thought maybe a little
funnier if he thought it was okay or you
know something like that or even a dingo
a trout just something a little
different but I think just him crying
else are like and it could have been
something else there but yeah it's fine
um and it's it's just a fun waste of
time episode it's weird it's strange the
the one of the things I do that really
stands out to me I don't know why I'm
wonder if you noticed it too or maybe I
just was reading too much into it but
the for some reason the color in the
first half before it gets really cloudy
out something about the color really
popped in this did you get that all like
the green looked particularly really
sharp and this guy looked like I don't
know it seems sharper than you during
what during the episode during the first
half the episode before I got cloudy
though
the point I think was well he's making
this everything is so bright and perfect
and great that when he tries to make the
sandwich again ulsan everything is do ya
brain dull nobody even before I got it
one gray and dull like something about
like when BMO was bill me building the
the ramp and everything just something
about the color seemed especially
vibrant about it I don't know cuz they I
don't even know what they would do or
whatever I like I said maybe it's just
me and maybe it's just something about
being a week of May just being a week
away from adventure time and not seeing
a super friend episode that's something
I don't know but I technically ways
we've been two weeks away right or is it
one week one wasn't one okay I did them
last week okay did we yes
what was the week we had bread over and
did that was like two weeks ago I was
two weeks ago okay my bed um so yeah
yeah okay anyway um so ya know it was
fun it was enjoyable
it was I love the time bubble I thought
that was surreal um you know and funny I
love magic man I love the little portals
he makes just a slap him you know you
just go up and slap him he has to make
these dumb portals totally do that if I
could why even give him a riddle to
figure it out it doesn't you know these
are hard you try to come up with one so
I yeah I thought was fine I thought was
funny yeah I mean it this is one of
those were used where you're deaf of
your definition your phrase it's a fun
waste of time yeah I think that's very
much true with this one I really enjoyed
it's a lot of fun but there's really
nothing
there's no preferring the plotline like
this is like an average episode of an
average cartoon and what I mean by that
is there's no storyline yeah it's
totally self-contained
I mean you have to know what the
characters are obviously but yeah while
ago I showed this to Jory rest in peace
by the way it's still juiced um you
should really clean her up over there I
mean it's just down the ground for a
while most slip coming in almost the
point that's something you'd fall yeah
well it's good a temp but clearly didn't
work
we know when George was originally I
showed it to her because
that's how she is when she makes a
sandwich she's all into it and it's like
she's like making art it's great you
know one like putting like mustard or
ketchup or anything on anything she's
like dude yes it's great but now she's
like now it makes so much more to me now
that I know all the characters hmm
so it's fun to watch without knowing
anyone but when you actually know the
characters it makes more sense yeah and
I do have there is something to like you
know when Jake comes in let's the
creative light died on him and it's I
mean the two things I think I see that
one is that for me anyway it's really
weird but if it's like a really bright
sunny day and it's nice so I do work a
lot better like I actually do force
myself to get up early in the morning
even though I hate getting up in the
morning but I force myself to do it
because I know I'll work better I'll
work faster I'll be more focused and I
actually it used to be that way around
used to be like in nighttime because you
know like nobody nobody was around I've
been everybody's asleep but now it's
like I think with our generation we just
all grown up staying up really late so
like everyone is a president everybody's
talking so it now it's like morning is
kind of like the quiet time now and like
the private time where you can sort of
like let your mind flow and stuff so no
thank you
so you stay away from me I'll have my
next time all to myself but but the
other thing that I always see people
like people who can cook I mean like
like you were talking about you know
make like an art form with yeah stuff
like that it's those people I respect
the hell out of because I can't do it at
all I cannot cook a thing at the most I
can do is macaroni and cheese I mean
that's what I had and it did not turn
out well yeah we saw
but like no I know a lot because a lot
of people around me get my wife can cook
my brother can cook his wife can cook I
don't mean like just oh they can make a
meal like I mean like particularly Rob
and his wife like when they put them
together they'll just like Chef Ramsay
and it just make it like a work of art
or something like that you'll just see
them do like it's like watching a
painter or paint something this canvas
you know these certain strokes and so
you just see like with the salt oh just
you know no no the butter is only gotta
be true like that it's like watching a
magic trick or something and they like
so get into it but it's the fruit tastes
really good it always looks unbelievable
it looks like a friggin sculpture and I
don't want to eat it but it tastes
really good so I eat it you know why
because they don't follow the
instructions that's probably very true I
cannot I can't do that exactly and I
can't not follow them either like the
worst of both worlds because I'm so bad
at that whenever I make something I have
to like follow like what's going on or
I'll screw it up yeah Joris joints the
same way though where she can kind of
split I need some more salt we'll do
this much and we'll do this you know she
doesn't measure she just kind of does
and it turns out great at best wife ever
she cooks the best I don't care what
anyone says even though she's juice on
the floor yeah it's gonna be hard for
her to cook now DMX
why don't we cook with the jewelry with
Jory like we can pull it around some
stuff you know like anabolism Oh kind of
I mean if we put it on something one
Annie okay I know cannibalism is eating
the same species is you but what about
drinking let's say let's say you take
someone you toss them in like a blender
turn it into like a liquid and then you
drink it I mean would that still be
cannibalism bottle that could be
possible mmm I think we've clearly run
out of material for this beam log no I
can't keep going on with the whole
cannibalism like there's this one movie
I saw where his face was ripped off and
then shoved into his own mouth and
they're bringing up the question is that
cannibalism or not and I guess it's
called auto cannibal oh my god oh hey
Jory hey no that's not Jory what is this
it's just pee that thought that clearly
didn't work how us buddy I wanted to hit
you sir
I don't get it what was that all right
don't catch it mister okay so cinder
oh yeah I don't get his comedy either
man